لذلك
المشهد في في الغرب او في الشرق تطور
بتطور بشكل كبير في العالم العربي ولله
الحمد شهدت نقلات يعني جدا كبيره خلال
العشر سنوات السابقه وطبعا العالم العربي
يعني منطقه جغرافيه كبيره لما نتكلم عن
العلم العربي نتكلم عن بلدان مختلفه بعضها
خطط خطوات جدا ممتازه لدعم رياده الاعمال
والصناديق الاستثماريه ونذكر على راس
القائمه السعوديه والامارات ومصر وهي اتت
بالفعل على راس القائمه في حجم التمويلات
التي تمت في عام
لذلك اجابه على سؤالك استاذه منتهى الرحله
ليست سهله شاقه في البلدان المتطوره وفي
بلدان العالم العربي وفي نصيحه مثلا ذهبيه
ممكن تقديمها هؤلاء الشباب بتعرف في عالم
الرومانسيه يقال لهم دائما ان تؤمن بما
تقوم به وان يعني تبقى
ملاحقا لحلمك حتى اللحظه الاخيره هل هذه
كافيه ام ان الايمان بما يقوم به الشخص
يجب ان يكون مدعوم ايضا
بايمان بمن حوله او ايمان للشركات او
المؤسسات او حتى الدوله بتمويله انا اعتقد
اذا كممولين اذا لم نجد فريق عمل مؤمن بما
يقوم به هذا بالنسبه للممول هذا بالنسبه
لهم يعتبر ديل بريكر فالممول لن يقوم
بالتمويل اذا لم يجد فريق مؤمن بالفكره
اللي هو شغال عليها هذا رقم واحد رقم
اثنين لازم يكون السوق كبير جدا
للنجاح لانه المستثمر ورائد الاعمال كل
منهما يسعى الى الربح وهي يعني هي عباره
زي ما نقول للجميع لرائد الاعمال
وللمستثمر لذلك هي رحله طويله اذا لم يوجد
شغف لدى رائد الاعمال بما يقوم به او فريق
العمل بشكل عام وكذلك من وجهه نظر
المستثمر ايمان بالسوق وبالفريق المؤسس
لما هم بصدد القيام فيه لان رحله طويله
ثمان سنوات سبع سنوات هي متوسط رحله رائد
الاعمال في هذه الرحله فالوصايا
الرومانسيه اللي احنا نسمعها دائما هي
حقيقه لكن بنفس الوقت يفترض انها تدعم
بالحقائق والخبرات
فالمستثمر اذا وجد شغف وكذلك خبرات وكذلك
سوق كبير
قابل
انه رائد الاعمال بامكانه الوصول اليه هذا
كل ما يسعى اليه اراد الاعمال وكذلك
المستثمر